just the vacation spot for me but is it
only a vacation spot or would I have to
work there you wouldn't have to work
there if you owned it a lot of people do
work there there are four full-time the
Cowboys what are we talking about first
off so this is in Montana it's around an
hour's drive from Bozeman it's in the
kind of southern part of the state this
is Big Sky Country and a pretty
literally close to Big Sky Montana yes
this is a home this is a home I mean a
single-family home yes it's so this was
a working ranch that this venture
capitalist named Robert birch who's the
former brother-in-law of Tory Burch okay
yes he and his wife kind of bought this
property for less than ten million
dollars it was around 9,000 acres and
then said about landscaping it and kind
of building this massive very beautiful
house and kind of expanded it to a
30,000 acre property which they're now
selling for thirty five million dollars
Wow so Chris Burgess brother did this as
a project I imagine this is where Mike
McKee is right now spending his time or
David Coe talk and a bunch of economists
waiting for the Jackson Hole speeches
but who who does hangout here on a
regular basis well there are four
Cowboys like literal full-time Cowboys
who all have houses on the property and
they are obviously paid salaries but
they're also paid what's called half a
beef which is what virtually was
standard cowboy compensation everyone
gets half a cow a year at the end of the
season yeah presumably and so they they
manage this around a thousand head of
cattle it's a cow calf operation which
means that basically they raise calves
until there are around eight hundred
pounds and then sell them and that's how
the ranch sustains itself 30,000 acres
that's a lot of lawn to have to mow yeah
well I mean you know he talked about
having all these different kind of ATVs
and motorcycles and you just
get around the property in a single day
I mean it's 12 miles long around 8 miles
wide there's the Yellowstone National
River that goes through it I mean this
is massive so why I mean it looks like
literally the for me the perfect place
to live why would he want to sell it you
know they said that they wanted to
downsize a little bit and get a smaller
ranch
um maybe down to 15,000 yeah something
modest like that pretty much said map is
the market is the market ripe for
selling I mean our property prices up
there that's a good question
property prices for ranches of this size
are I mean this is kind of a unique
proposition they're already out there
right well and there aren't many with
like beautiful mansions that have been
professionally designed and with all
this landscaping I mean there are a lot
of functional ranches which sell for a
decent amount of money but there aren't
a lot of ranches like this what did you
hear about the level of interest and the
kinds of buyers that this would appeal
to yeah so this is I mean obviously on a
certain level this could apply to
someone who appeal rather to someone who
had commercial interests you know
there's space to actually increase the
operation to the extent that it would
actually be significantly profitable if
they wanted to raise the head of cattle
I mean the way that this is currently
broken down is that there's a kind of
big emphasis on nature right you could
actually make it more of an operation
and put a lot more a kind of
money-making facility you could make it
a legit working cowboy business exactly
but then again you can also turn this
into a bonafide resort as well pretty
easily and so apparently there's
interest from both angles though it has
you could make it at Montana Morrow logo
I'm not sure anyone could do that but
not it certainly try